we start with a tough story here that
for the first time we're hearing from
the family of a nine year old boy
accused of intentionally setting a
deadly home fire in Illinois Kyle
Allwood is charged with five counts of
first degree murder his mother allowed
us to disclose his name and his picture
five people died in the April fire
including some of Kyle's young relatives
Errol Barnett spoke exclusively with
Kyle's mother he's in Eureka Illinois
Errol what did she say well Katie Elwood
tells us prosecutors have gone too far
in charging her son and because of
multiple death threats he's now having
to live with other relatives but she
also tells us he was recently diagnosed
with a form of schizophrenia ADHD and
bipolar disorder but keep this in mind
despite being distraught describing that
horrific night to us she says her son is
a loving person who deserves a second
chance everyone is looking at him like
he's some kind of monster but that's not
who he is
Katie Elwood fighting back tears as she
speaks about her nine-year-old son Kyle
charged this week with killing five
people one night back in April by
setting fire to the family home people
make mistakes and that's what this is
yes it was a horrible tragedy but it's
still not something to throw his life
away over the victims are all members of
the family
Katie's other children Damien and Ariel
her grandmother Katherine a fiancé Jason
wall and her niece Rose Katie was in the
home when the fire broke out while most
of the victims were sleeping but was
only able to save herself I stood at the
window and I told my kids I was sorry I
couldn't save them mommy was right here
and I loved them you know so at least
hopefully they heard that you know I
told Jason I love him I'll always love
him and then I just something told me
that they're gone so there was a moment
where you could hear them screaming yeah
you could hate your fiance
and then it ended I don't know what's
worse hearing him scream or what it
stopped
we walked with Katie through her sister
Samantha Elwood's home next door
Samantha was roses mother she got me she
made my days better unlike her sister
Samantha wants a nephew Kyle to face a
strict punishment I think he should go
somewhere until he's legal age to go to
juvie
then I think he should go to juvie and
then from juvie to prison because at the
end of the day whether he meant to or
not he knew what fired constitutional
law professor Gloria Brown Marshall says
pinning a murder charge on a child is an
abuse of power by the prosecutor it's
difficult to understand how a nine year
old would have the state of mind to know
that their action would result in a
death Katie Allwood says her son
deserves to pay for his alleged actions
but says the family has already suffered
enough I did lose you know my family too
but I forgive him I love him no matter
what now Katie said that Kyle had
previously shown an interest in lighters
and in fire but she hopes that the judge
takes into consideration his mental
state as well as the person she says he
is now the local prosecutor here tells
us that they are defending the decision
to file murder charges in the Kyle is
only likely to face probation that young
boy will face a judge here at this
courthouse on the 21st
Tony Wow Errol it's a powerful interview
and you lay out the story so well a very
disturbing I mean it's a really tough
one yeah just a complete tragedy for
that family all the way around they'll
never be the same yeah and you can
understand what the mother doesn't want
to lose it really an infected an
additional child that's like that
putting it all the way forever you know
alright Errol thank you very much